[موسيقى]
مساء الخير على حضراتكم وحلقه جديده من
حلقات الاعلام الاسرائيلي ومتابعه اخبار
دوله الاحتلال وصديقنا الدكتور احمد فؤاد
انور مساء الخير مع الدكتور اهلا سيد بيه
صديقي الغالي ربنا يخليك ويسعدك كالعاده
عندنا وجبه دسمه من اخبار وتحليلات ما
يجري في دوله الاحتلال هل ممكن نبدا
النهارده بدل من غزه نبدا بالضفه لانه
الاحداث في الضفه برض ليست قليله يعني هل
بايجاز شديد الوضع في الضفه الان اكثر
سخونه
ا منذ الاسابيع الاولى بعد 7 اكتوبر ام
انه اكثر هدوءا ولماذا يعني ممكن نقسم ل
مساحتين او مستويين المستوى الاول هو
الاقصى الاقتحامات الاقصى السيد قلت من
جانب المستوطنين من جانب قطعان المستوطنين
وتدنيس الاقصى من خلال حمايه شرطه
الاحتلال لهم واستفزاز المشاعر الحديث عن
ان قعاده الهيكل بناء الهيكل مفروضه وقربت
وان المكان بتاعنا ممكن نصلي فيه رغم ان
القانون الاسرائيلي نفسه يمنع بيسمحوا لهم
بالزياره يمنع صلاه اليهود داخل سموه جبل
الهيكل اللي هو الحرم القدسي الشريف
فبالتالي ده بعد يعني هم بيقولوا ان ده
الوفان الاقصى مالوش علاقه بالضفه ولا
بالاقصى ولا الانتهاكات المستدامه الدائره
ضد سكان الضفه الروايه الاسال كده انما
على ارض الواقع بنجد ان بالفعل طوفان
الاقصى خفف عدد
ووتيرة عن اغتيال داخل مستشفى
لثلاثه من الشباب ده من حوالي اسبوع اه 17
سنه 18 سنه اعتقد ان هم واحد فيهم شلل
نصفي يعالج من ثلاث شهور ويع طفل يعني في
ان هو مش شاب يافع يعني هو بينهي مرحله
الطفوله
و يعني عامل زي فيلم ولاد العا كان في
فيلم لقطه شريف عارف اشاور بيها مع عمرو
سمير عاطف ان ما تصدقوش الروايه
الاسرائيليه الجار المشلول اللي قاعد على
الكرسي انت حضرتك ما شفتش الفيلم كويس قام
في نص الفيلم ومسك سكينه وكان هيقتل جارته
المسلمه اللي هي مفترض ان دول جيران طيبين
هو والجاره برض رفعت مسدس الفيلم ده تحقق
على ارض الواقع الاسبوع اللي فات وجدنا ان
واحد يا عيني كسيح داخل المستشفى خاصه في
شكل شخص كسيح بالضبط وان بيدفعوا العربيه
بتاع الكسيح ده وان في اللي هي بتاعه
البيبي ديت برضو بيشيلوا فيها الطفل
الرضيع دوت وغلابه وداخلين يتعالجوا زي
بقيه الناس او زي الدكاتره وفجاه لقينا
الكسيح ده قام وماسك رشاش وبيحارب
دكاتره ومريض عنده شلل نصف انت بتشير الى
عدد من القوات الخاصه الاسرائيليه اللي
اقتحمت احدى المستشفيات في الضفه الغربيه
وا كانت بتستهدف مجموعه ممن تعتبرهم ايه
مصدر خطر عليها مبوط صح اه نفتالي بينت ده
كان رئيس وزراء سابق قعدوا يحققوا معاه
صحفيا يعني لقاء تلفزيوني في قناه غربيه
يعني ينفع تقتحم مستشفى يعني ده بيمثل لكم
خطوره ايه اللي انت شايف من الناحيه
الانسانيه ايه فابتدا يهاجم المذيعه
والقناه وان دول معادين للساميه وان انتم
يعني يعني مش مراعيين وان انا مع العمليه
دي ده ال اه بس هي في النهايه بقول ان يلا
نمسح حواره البلده اللي كان التهديد اللي
كان اطلقه سمت شزين الماليه يلا نمسح من
على الخريطه حو دي تراجعه النغمه دي يعني
بقى في عمليات نوعيه في اعتقالات صحيح
انما في النهايه اعتقد ان المنسوب بيقل
بالتدريج في الضفه الغربيه وانت بترجع ده
لاسباب منها منها ان طوفان الاقصى مرتبط
بالاحداث في الضفه فعايزين ينزعوا عنه
الجزئيه دي يقولوا لا انت من نفسك كده امت
يوم سبعه ايه اعتديت علينا فما فيش حاجه
في الضفه الضفه كويسه وهاديه رغم ان حضرتك
خد بالك السيد بيخشوا يجرفه البنيه
التحتيه يعني مش
بيلاحقني للمقاومه هو بيهد المخيم من
الداخل بيجر في الاسفلت نفسه الصرف الصحي
فده بعد البعد الثاني ان كون هدفه من كده
ايه انه الحضه الشعبيه للمقاومه تقل يا
جماعه ما تخشوش بقى ايه في صدام مع
الاحتلال عشان هيجي يجرفه المخيم كله مش
هيقبضوا عليك انت ولا هدوا بيتك انت بس
ففي هدم منازل ايوه في عمليات نوعيه ايوه
في بس الوتيره والمنسوب بيقل سببين
المقاومه انها بتقول احنا بنبص للاحتلال
بشكل عام مش ما نتعرض له في غزه فقط
الحاجه الثانيه ان الراي العام العربي
والاسلامي بيعني طبعا ينتفض يعني بيقول لا
ما يصحش حتى الغرب يعني مش جنوب افريقيا
بس في دول زي كندا زي الولايات المتحده زي
ايرلندا بيطلعوا في مظاهرات الفكره
الاساسيه ان الوضع في شمال غزه رغم سحب
الالويه وان الاوضاع مفترض تكون
استقرت حماس اداره حماس بقت توزع 200
دولار على
موظفيها في شمال شمال غزه في الويه انسحبت
اه الويه اسرائيليه الويه اسرائيليه
واعتبرت ان شمال غزه بقى مستقر المفروض
مستقر وتم تطير وتحطيم الالويه والكتاب
ففوجئنا بمؤشر واحد ان القوات الخاصه
بالشرطه الحمساويه رجعت ابتدت توزع 200
دولار للموظفين كرواتب يعني كرواتب انها
تضبط الامن ان في ناس لصوص للمنازل في ناس
تم اجلائهم
ا بسبب الضغوط والارهاب الاسرائيلي فم لاز
ال فدخلوا فال الشرطه الفلسطينيه العائده
القت القبض عليه اه فانت بتقول ده في اطار
في اطار ان اداره شمال غزه تعود بالتدريج
لحماس فبالتالي انا في الضفه الغربيه مش
عايز افتح جبهه تانيه خاصه رمضان داخل فف
جاه مش هقول بقى ان انا بطلت ضغط في الضفه
انا ققول بالتدريج انا ايه بقلل الوتيره
انت كده مش بتقول سببين انت بتقول كده
ثلاثه السبب الاولاني واحد انه يعني تسلب
المقاومه حجتها فيان هجومها كان مبنيا على
استفزت اسرائيليه ليس فقط ضد سكان غزه
ولكن ضد اهالي الضفه صحيح اثنين انه
المعركه لم تنتهي بعد في غزه حتى في شمال
غزه التي عادت اليها الشرطه والقوات
الخاصه الحمساويه وبالتالي اسرائيل ليس من
مصلحتها ان تفتح جبهه جديده ا في الضفه
بينما الضفه الجبهه اساسيه لم تغلق اه
الجانب الاسرايلي كمان بيقول طب حكمل
العنصر والسبب الثالث اللي انت قلته بقى
استفزاز الراي العام العالمي اذا كان عربي
اسلامي غربي الجانب الاسرائيلي بيعترف بان
في معارك شمال غزه هو اللي بيدعي يعني في
مئات من المخربين بين قوسين تم قتلهم في
غزه في مدينه غزه انت مش قلت طهرت هو لسه
في مئات اه تناقد صح اه يعني ازاي في كده
جيش كامل موجود ل لسه بيقاوم وانت انتصرت
عليه امبارح امال اول امبارح كان ايه
الوضع من شهر انا هستاذنك ارجع
لغزه وتطورات الوضع فيها ولكن انا قبل ما
اسيب
الضفه وبقطع النظر عن الهدوء النسبي الى
ان الاوضاع ملتهبه طبعا كان في واقعه
تتعلق باعتداء متطرفين مستوطنين ليس
على الغالبيه من الفلسطينيين المسلمين
ولكن على المسيحيين ايضا سواء كانوا
فلسطينيين او غير فلسطينيين من الرهبان
الكثيرين اللي موجودين هناك في الضفه
الغربيه الكلام ده صحيح ولا غير صحيح اه
صحيح طبعا اخر حادثه ان يوم اربعه الشهر
ده اللي هو اول امبارح واحنا بنسجل كان في
باقه جديده واشتباك جديد بين المستوطنين
دول ورجل دين مسيحي راهب مسيحي راجل مسالم
يعني مجارد ان هو بيمر فهو الاتنين
المستوطنين دول قاعدين ايه يقول ده راهب
ويسيب السيد المسيح هو الكلام ده دار في
احد اديره القدس لا لا في احد ازقه القدس
شوار القدس فهو الراهب بقى خبره لان عمليه
البسق دي ظاهره انه ظاهره البسق على ر على
رجال الدين هو ده بيرجع للخا اللي هي
الشريعه اليهوديه اه يعني انا عايز اقول
ان اولا هو كلم
الشرطه هذا الراهب والشرطه اللي تصوره صور
هذا المعتدي هذا المعتدي فالمعتبر لو
يهودي هيحصل اللي حصل ايه هو اللي حصل ان
هو صوره وثبت ان هو بالكاميرات ارتكب
الحكايه ديت والاهانه ديت وروح البيت ا لم
يتم القبض عليه لا يعني انت انت ايوه انا
انا فيعني مع السلامه يجوز لك ان تفعل ذلك
فهو الفكره ان في يعني هو الجانب اليهودي
المتدين المتشدد دينيا اقرب للمسلمين عن
المسيحيه الديانه المسيحيه بالنسبه له
بتبقى فيها حس يه كبيره جدا لدرجه ان هو
يحرق الاناجيل لو لقاها
بالعبريه ممنوع يجمعها ويعمل زي حفله
بتقول المتدينين دول المتشددين اليهود هم
اكثر تطرفا تجاه المسيحيين اه من موقفهم
من المسلمين اه طبعا اه ليه لان هو لما
يعدي على المقابر المسيحيه يعدي على
الكنيسه يبتدي يسب السيد السيد المسيح
والسيده مريم العذراء فده من من ضمن اللي
هو ايه يعني بيسبح وهوو كده ايه بيقول
تراتيل فيها سباب فهو انت حضرتك بتنده
والناس اللي هم بيسموهم ايه العقلاء او
متزنين انما هو شخص مش متزن يعني هو ضد
الاغيار هو مش موضوع ان ده مسيحي هو في
سنه 2009 طلع كتاب شريعه الملك نقتل
الاطفال من الجيم اغيار في الحرب وفي
السلم
لدرجه انه يقول لك ايه ما تستلف من
الاغيار ولا تسلف فقال لك طب ما نستلف
منهم هضايق يعني انت كده اهو بتضايق
الاغيار دي حاجه كويسه لا ما انت في يوم
من الايام قد تضطر وترجع له القرض هتفرحه
ده كل ده موجود نصا ولا على سبيل المحلا
دي دي بيسموها اسئله واجوبه الفتاوي وهذه
الاسئله والاجوبه اللي انت اشرت لبعضها ده
مكتوب في كتاب شريعه الملك شريعه الملك
اقتل اطفال في السلم والحر من الاغيار اما
الامثله الاخرى اللي انت اشرت اليها دي دي
فتاوى موجوده في مصادر اخرى ا ده العادي
اه ثابته يعني طيب عظيم جدا هل انت تحب
توضح لنا الصوره انت قلت كده وقعه البسق
دي البسق على مرتبطه بظاهره متكرره في
الاسابيع الاخيره تصاعدت وهي الفكره
العنصريه ضد المسيحيين ديت مرتبطه ايضا
بالتجاوز ضد بابا الفاتيكان لان كان ليه
تصريح يا جماعه جماعه نوقف الحرب دي ونطلق
السراح الاسرى تخيل برض كم السباب وال
والتجاوزات ضد بابا الفاتيكان في مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي بقى اه المدونات وما
الى ذلك يعني نوصل الى ان الموضوع مرتبط
كمان
بدير السلطان يعني هو مش بو الفاتيكان بس
ولا الرهبان الذين يروهم في الازقه انما
كمان عندنا موضوع دير السلطان اللي هو كل
شهر اربعه بتحصل فيه خناقه كبيره جدا
واشتباك والشرطه الاسرائيليه تنحاز ضد
الرهبان المصريين ايه هو دير السلطان
الاول عشان نفهم القصه وبعدين نفهم ايه
اللي بيحصل كل شهر ابريل في كنيسه القيامه
في القدس في عده اديره منها دير السلطان
ده دير مصري تاريخيا وواقعيا وعمليا ففي
يوم طلعوا الرهبان
يحتفلوا زي كل سنه ا وجدوا ان
رهبان الاحباش من اثيوبيا قفلوا بقفل هو
زي سطح ممر على سطح ا فوق الكنيسه فالمهم
ان هو قفلوا البوابه اه وقالوا خلاص احنا
دي السلطان معانا اثيوبي اه اثيوبي اه وهم
طبعا يعني طالعين مستقلين من الكنيسه
المصريه كنيسه الاسكندريه
فده رحنا المحكمه احنا مصر رحنا المحكمه
الاسرائيليه حكمت لنا ولغايه دلوقتي من
سنه 70 ما فيش تنفيذ للحكم طب هل تسمح لي
اعمل خلفيه سريعه لمن لا يعلم وصحح ني
يعني دي تبقى فرصه وطبعا احنا الغالبيه من
المسيحيين الغالبيه الكبرى من المسيحيين
المصريين هم من ال من الارثوذكس صحيح
والغالبيه من المسيحيين الاثيوبيين من
الارثوذكس صحيح وكانوا يتبعون الكنيسه
المصريه ومقرها في الاسكندريه صحيح الى ان
قررت اثيوبيا الانفصال عن الكنيسه المصريه
لاسباب يطول شرحها معظمها يعني سياسي في
السبعينات دير السلطان اللي هو موجود في
قدس الشرقيه مظبوط يا دكتور اكيد اي في
البلده القديمه اه في البلده القديمه دير
السلطان ده كان دير مصري وفيه رهبان
مصريين ولكن مع بعد انفصال الكنيسه
الارثوذكسيه الحبشيه او الاثيوبيه اصبح
هناك نزاع لان الكنيسه او الاحباش او
الاثيوبيين بيقولوا هذه كنيستنا وعندنا
وثائق ملكيه ولكن وثائق الملكيه دي لما
ذهبت الى المحكمه قالوا ان هي
ايه موجوده ق اه الاوبين قالوا كان عندنا
ا بس اتح ا ف فال المحكمه الاسرائيليه
حكمت بان هذا الدير لمصر تذكر الحكم ده
كان سنه كام دكوره سنه 70 لكن رغم صدور
هذا الحكم الى ان المساله ما زالت محل
صراع مباشر او نزاع ما بين الاثيوبيين
الناحيه والرهبان الاثيوبيين من الناحيه
اللي الموجودين في اسرائيل خاله الحز وال
الرهبان المسيحيين المصريين وانت بتقول
بقى شرطه الاحتلال بنحاس تنحس دوما
الاثيوبيين ورصدنا اكثر من يعني اعتداء
بدني على الرهبان من قبل شرطه الاحتلال ده
بيتصا مع كل
عيد في هذا السياق انا شايف ان الموضوع ده
مش صدفه ومش اعتباطا انما معقبه للكنيسه
المصريه لمواقفها الوطنيه يعني ص البابا
شنوده هو اول من قال ندخل القدس اه في
الحج المفروض يبقى فيه زياره دينيه فالمهم
قال ندخل وادينا في ايدين اشقائنا
المسلمين مش عايزين لم يسمح وطبعا نيافه
الانبا ابو خوميوك
المحترم خضص البابا توادروس كان ليا شرف
ان انا يعني اطلع رحله خارج مصر في وفد
كان هو على راسه فاقتربت منه انسانيه لا
شخصيه وطنيه
بامتياز لها مواقف توجع اسرائيل يعني
اسرائيل كانت عايزه سيناريو معين تهييج
معين تطبيع معين ما لقيتوش فابتدا يحصل
على الاقل من جانب المسيحيين يعني من
الكنيسه ان ممكن تبقى هي منفصله عن موقف
شيخ الازهر مثلا وال المشيح اه اه اه طيب
عظيم جدا ا بعيدا عن هذا الملف احنا عندنا
او مش بعيدا قوي احنا عندنا ا في مجموعه
من اللي بيتحسبوا على الجناح المتطرف دول
مش اكتفوا بالبثق على الرهبان المسيحيين
اذا كانوا مصريين او غير مصريين يعني اي
رهبان يعني مسيحيين لكن دول هددوا الحكومه
الاسرائيليه واعضاء كنيست
ا لاعتقادهم انهم تخاذلوا في ممارسه مزيد
من العنف تجاه الفلسطينيين ممكن تشرح لنا
اللي حصل كده وابعاده ا ما حدث ان في في
مجموعه تاسست منذ سنوات من غلاه المتطرفين
دول بيدعوا للانتقام يدعوا للانتقام طبعا
من الفلسطينيين لك انت تورطت انت شاركت
انت متهم بعمليه ارهابيه انا هجيب اسرتك
هجيب
ممتلكاتك هنتقم منك بعيدا عن القانون يعني
اه بعيدا بيسموها محتاره اللي هي منظمه
سريه عصابه محتت اللي هو حاجه بتشتغل تحت
الارض غير قانونيه عصابه تحت الارض خارج
القانون وفي جزء منها
بتلحق الشبك اللي هو الاستخبارات الداخليه
في اداره للارهاب اليهودي اللي هم المفروض
بن جفير و سمتش والمجموعه دي كان لهم مل
زباين زباين عندهم فالمفروض يبقوا مكانهم
السجن بقوا هم مديرين ومشرفين على هذه
الادارات التي كانت تلحقوا فده بعد البعد
المستجد ان
الجماعات المسؤولين الاعضاء في الائتلاف
الحكومي لاوا
بطايقهم على با بيتهم مع جواب بخط الايد
ان احنا جماعه المنتقمين وان احنا يعني
المنتقمين لا لا القمم دي هو المنتقم
الجمع منتقمون انما المحتر دي اي عصابه اي
اصابه بتشتغل تحت الارض المنظمه السريه
تحت الارض المهم ان هم المسؤولين لقم على
باب
البيت رقم الهويه بتاعته صوره منها وان
احنا هننتخب منك
ومن ابنائك ومن احفادك فهو الفكره بس ان
هو ابتدى يستهدفهم بالشرطه ابتدت تتحرك
وابتدا يبقى في نوع من الهلع خاصه ان مثلا
استروكس قصدي استروك دي وزيره متطرفه هي
وزيره الاستيطان مخلفه 11 فشوف ال 11 دول
بقى الاحفاد كام فالامن هيام من مين ولا
مين وهي سن متدينه فتخلف كتير لازم اه
فالجزء المهم كمان انها كانت دايما تقول
ما بعرفش اكمل الشهر ما انت مخلفه 11 ما
بتعرفش تكمل الشهر يعني المرتب مش مقضي هي
بتقول كده فعلا اه وتبرعوا للسياده
الوزيره وبقت مدع السخريه لا لا هي قالت
عشان كده بخروا منها احنا ما بنعرفش نكمل
الشهر ما انت مخلفه
11 تبرع لسياده الوزيره
يعني بعت لك الكاريكاتير كمان لان الامن
بقى واقف وهي نازله تشحت الامن والعربيه
الفارهه واقفه في الاشاره وهي نازله
تلقط طيب برضو مش بعيد قوي عن الجماعه او
اصحاب الطيارات اللي هي من متشدده
لمتطرفين درجات يعني احنا عندنا ليبرمان
اللي هو كان وزير خارجيه ووزير دفاع سابق
لاسرائيل وزير استيعاب وح والان وطبعا هو
شخصيه برض يعني لها وزن في السياسه
الاسرائيليه رغم ان انت كنت اشرت الى
خلفيته بشكل
يعني اه اه لكن ليبرمان انا ليبرمان ده
كان اول مره اسمع عنه بالمناسبه كان في
منتصف التسعينات على ما اذكر يعني كان هدد
بضرب السد العالي في مصر اي واذكر ان كانت
من المرات اللي
هي الاولى بعد كده مبارك بقى يعقب اكثر
يعني نعقب بشكل كان في يعني شده وحده على
هذه القصه يعني واذكر برض ان الراجل ده
اصبح لما اصبح بعد كده وزير خارجيه تمت
مقاطعته من الدول العربيه هو كان في خارج
الحكومه وقال التصريح ده نضرب طهران اسوان
قصده سد اسوان فلما استلم وزير خارجيه بقى
في الحكومه ما بقالوش اكل عيش في الدول
العربيه يعني الاردن ومصر اطعو ما عتبها
طيب ليبرمان دلوقتي اللي هو خارج السلطه
ا هاجم مصر او اعتبرها مسؤوله عنما يجري
في اسرائيل ايه القصه يعني يعني هو بيقول
احنا هو بيقول فين بقى في على على تويتر
مثلا ولا في مقال ولا منتديات محاضرات
بلقيها مصوره يعني فبيقول احنا داخلين على
125 يوم وانا بهاجم الحكومه الحكومه ماشي
غلط هو طبعا ماتخدش في حكومه الحرب
ما يعني واعتقد ان هو مش عايز يخش كمان
انما في النهايه هو ممثل للمهاجرين الروس
ليثقل وطبعا حتى ان لكنته في العبريه لسه
فيها بقايا اللغه الروسيه انما بيمثل تيار
يميني متشدد ويمثل المهاجرين الجدد حوالي
مليون واحد داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي ما
يستهن بيهم ده هم الجدد دول يعني اللي هم
جم من بعد ايه بقى من بعد تفكك الاتحاد
السوفيتي باب الهجره اتفتح فبقى في مليون
واحد ودول بالمناسبه اغلبهم في البطاقه
انت ديانتك ايه تحت الفحص يعني المليون
ولا كثير منهم المليون اغلبهم اغلبهم ليه
لان انت ماعرفش انت يهودي ولا لا ام ونفس
الامر مع الاثيوبيين رغم ان بتكذبوا
الديانه تحت الفحص تحت الفحص ان شاء الله
سه ما هو بيموت وحتى ما يفنش مع اليهود
لانه مش
يهودي دي بين قوسين كده بين قوسين مهمه
طيب ليبرمان قال ايه عن مصر اه ليبرمان
طبعا بيقول احنا دخلنا في 125 يوم بسبب
مصر مصر افلت انها تحكم اغلاق
مع المحور فيلا دلفي فبالتالي في انفاق
تحتيه الانفاق دي تدخل سلاح واحنا يعني في
عشرات على الاقل من الانفاق لسه
فهو مصر الانفا انفاق شغاله اه في حاجات
اهدت انما في حاجات
مكمله بتعبر محور فيلادلفيا طب ايه ايه
الاقتراح يا استاذ
ليبرمان مصر برض تقلل عدد قواتها لانها
انتهكت
المعاهده هي مصر ما انتهكت المعاهده احنا
في 21 طرفين وافق اه 20 21 نوفمبر يوم 10
الطرفين وافقوا على حاجه الحاجه دي بق وضع
قانوني مستقر بعد 60 هو زياده عدد القوات
المصريه اللي موجوده في سينا فالشرط الاول
ان الاثنين يوافقوا على اي تعديل لازم
الاثنين يوافقوا اني حاجه حتى في على
معلومات القانونيه البسيطه بعد 60 يوم
القرار بيتحسن يعني انت عايز تسحب قرارك
تتحفظ عليه تشاور عقلك دامك 60 يوم يعني
انما بعد ثلاث سنين وشويه هتبتدي تقول لا
ممكن الطرفين لو اتفقوا خلاص يعني ما فيش
مشكله اه انما ما ينفعش ان انا اقول من
طرف واحد انا فهو بيهاجم مصر يعني للدلاله
على ان مصر مسؤوله اولا عن اداره
المفاوضات في الصفقه المتعثره بينهم وبين
حماس بشكل غير مباشر اه فيا ريت يا مصر مش
يا ريت يعني عايزين مصر تضغط اكتر لانها
هي السبب هي اللي دخلت الاسلحه دي وهي
انفاق دي هي اللي عملت المشاكل دي ل حضرتك
تذكر جلعاد شاليط هم كان في في حاجه اسمها
لجان المقاومه الجندي الاسرائيلي جلعاد
شليط الذي تم اسره وفي مقابله يعني اطلاق
سراحه من جانب حماس اطلق اكثر من 1000
منهم السنوار ريح السنو كان برض نفق دخل
عندكم يعني انتم اذا كنت انت بتعرف تضبط
الحدود قوي ما كان المحور معاك صحيح
الدكتور بيشير الى ان كان في نفق خارج من
غزه الى داخل اراضي
48 اه جاخد منه جلعاد جلعاد كان جوه دبابه
جوه معسكر جوه دبابه تاخد ا وكان في حد
تاني في الضفه برض تتاخد فانما انما اللي
عايز اشير اليه اذا كنت انت فاشل فما
تمسكش في مصر اذا كنت انت عايز تمسك في
مصر فانت ماسك كمان في قطر عمال تشاو في
قطر عمال جو تيرش الاونور وا حضرتك طلعت
المانشيت شريان الحياه لغزه بقى التعبير
متداول منك الفك لحضرتك انت لسه قلت ان في
حد مذيعه
بتكلم بنت رئيس ال الاي كان اول تهمه
بالنسبه انه انت معادات السمايه هي ظاهره
الحقيقه يعني ظاهره فكره انه كثير من
الاسرائيليين عندهم اعتقاد ان هم
محاصرين من عالم عربي مسلم مسيحي اغيار
جيوم يعني وهو راجل مش مسؤول انا ممكن
اقول نتحفظ على هذه الواقعه الواقعه دي
احنا اخطانا احنا لازم نحقق لا نوقف انما
هو بيقول لها انت السبب طب اذا احنا
بنتكلم خلاصه كلام ليفر انه هو بيعتبر مصر
مسؤوله عما تعانيه مص اسرائيل في غزه واحد
لانها لم تلعب دورا كافيا للضغط على حماس
في المفاوضات الجاريه لانهاء الحرب والتي
لن تنتهي الا بتسليم المحتجزين والاسر اه
ويسبق هذا عدم موافقتها على التهجير ان
احنا نصفي القضيه والموضوع يتحل على كده
ويسبق هذا عدم موافقتها على طلب بسيط جدا
من اسرائيل وهو السماح بف حدودها ل 2
مليون و400 الف فلسطيني الى سيناء واضف
الى ذلك وفقا لليبرمان انه هو بيتهم
بالتخاذل في احكام الانفاق اللي بيقول
انها موجوده وتمرر الاسلحه وربما اليها
يهرب بعض قيادات حماس مش هو ده خلاصه اللي
قاله ليبرمان صحيح صحيح عندي سؤال ليك انت
عاوز تقول حاجه اتفضل لا لا انا كنت بقول
ان هم بيقولوا احنا عارفين ان حماس معاها
60% من الاغاثه اللي بتخش هي اللي بتوزعها
احنا عارفين ان حماس في رفح هي اللي بتوزع
100% احنا عارفين ان السنوار كان هنا ومشي
انتم عارفين كل حاجه كده 7 اكتوبر بتتم
ازاي عارفين كل حاجه وما طلعتو ولا اثير
ولا محتجز ليه عارفين ان مصر والانفاق ما
تشوفوا من ناحيتكم انتوا اظبطوا الحدود من
ناحيتكم انتوا انا عاوز استاذنك واستاذن
اصدقائي انا قلت راي مشابه قبل الاحداث دي
كلها كان في حلقه بعنوان كيف تجند شبكه
نتفليكس
كيف يجند الموساد عملائه عبر شبكه نتفليكس
حاجه بالمعنى ده يعني ممكن تكتبه نتفليكس
كانت خلاصه الحلقه انه اسرائيل دايما
بتفخر جدا اظن ده من حوالي سنتين ثلاثه
كده بتفخر جدا ان هي عندها قدره هائله على
الاستخبارات قوه عظمى في الاستخبارات
ومستعده ان تساعد العالم كله بقدرتها
الاستثنائيه فانا بقول ان الكلام ده هم
عندهم جهاز استخباراتي كبير وناجح وعندهم
جيش قوي بس في مبالغه كتير قوي قوي قوي
طبعا والدليل ان هم عاجزين عن تحقيق
اختراقات في اقرب جبهتين لهمم جبهه الجنوب
التي احتلوها وما زالوا يراقبونها ليلا
ونهارا في غزه وجبهه الشمال التي احتلوها
وما زالوا
يراقبونها على حدودهم اللي هي في لبنان
التفاصيل موجوده فحقيق يعني انه اللي
بيتكلم على قدره اسرائيل الاستثنائيه يجب
ان يعني يتدبر الامور ويشوف ايوه انت عندك
جيش قوي انت عندك استخبار مبارات كويسه
لكن الكلام على ان هم
اساطير يعني بيتعارض مع الواقع اللي موجود
يعني لما كان في فاكسون ده الجندي واشرنا
ليه قبل كده في الضفه الغربيه حاولوا يحرر
موتوه والضباط اللي داخلين ي حررو ماتوا
بقت فضيحه اشرنا ليها قبل كده الواقعه دي
جلعاد شليط لم يخرج الا بالتفاوض
والمقاومه دلوقتي بتقول لهم انتوا لو
فتشتمل سيناء لن تستردوا اسراكم الا
بالتفاوض وبعد قصح غزه اه اه لو فتشت رمال
انا قلت ايه سينا رمال غزه لن تحصلوا على
اسراكم ولا محتجزي م الا بالتفاوض في
تطورات على صعيد العلاقه بين
الحليفين يعني القويين جدا الولايات
المتحده واسرائيل الخلافات دي بتزود يوم
بعد يوم صحيح تدينا فكره كده على قد ايه
الخلافات دي موجوده حقيقيه مبالغ فيها من
وجهه النظر الاسرائيليه يعني من وجهه
النظر الاسرائيليه هناك نبره تصعيديه ضد
ضد بايدن بت مجملها ان يعني انتم بتعتبرو
ولايه من الولايات وده غير صحيح وهو طبعا
غير صحيح هي الولايه الاولى مش من الولايه
من الولايات يعني الحاجه اللي بعدها ان
بايدن نفسه المشكله فيه انت ما بتحبش
نتنياهو انت من الاول قبل 7 اكتوبر بتقول
له وقف السياسه بتاعتك في الضفه هدي شويه
خلي وهو دلوقتي بيقول حاجه شبيهه قال عدد
القاتله مش مش مش ماقتلش يعني اه يعني قال
عدد القاتله فده الاداره الامريكيه بتشترك
تدريجيا وعلنيا مع نتنياهو والمجموعه
بتاعته فاحنا وصلنا لفين ان كان في اشتباك
بين نتنياهو وبين بايدن بعد كده ابتدى
يتسرب ان بايدن ابتدى يرد ان انا ما بردش
عليه التليفونات وان الصحف الامريكيه
بتقولوا ان هو وصفه سبه وقال هيز فاكين بد
جاي يعني اه ترجمه انيس بخش
يعني شخص شرير اه شرير وخد فده الجزء اللي
هو الاشتباك ده وصل لفين بقى ان بنج فير
دخل على الخط دخل لمجله امريكيه وابتدى
ايه يشتم في الاداره الامريكيه والسياسات
الامريكيه وان يعني بيتعاملوا معانا ليه
كده وان اصدقاء اه انما مش للدرجه دي ا
فابتدا نتنياهو يقول له في الاجتماع
الاخير يا بنج فير انا مش عايزز مساعدتك
في العلاقات الاسرائيليه الامريكيه تخشش ت
هو كان يقصد كده لان انا قريت عنوان لا
احتاج الى مساعده قصده على بن غفير اه يا
بن غفير اقعد كده اهد انا ما طلبتش
مساعدتك حطش التاتش بتاعك انا امريكاني
اصلا ما قالوش كده بس انا هو تقفيل
امريكاني صناعه امريكيه ففهم ويقدر فدي
حاجه الحاجه اللي بعدها ان طلع لنا كان
بيطلع لنا ابن نتنياهو دلوقتي طلع لنا ابن
بن جفير ابن بنج فير طلع بالويت وشتم فيها
بايدن قال المخرف ان العلاج بتاع الزهايمر
لازم نذاكره بقى عشان حاله بايدن ده كده
يعني لازم تحتاج ان احنا نشوف والاعراض
والعلاج وبتاع وابتدا يتريق ابتدى يسخر من
جد
بيض
فج والده طلع بقى ايه اعتذر لا الولد ما
يقصد ام ومسح التغرير يعني الولد اكثر
اعتدالا من ابيه يعني الولد الاب اللي هو
بن غفير اللي هو طبعا وزير الامن يعني
القومي اللي هو رمز للتطرف عنده ابني
بيغال عليه اه بيزايد عليه رسام الكركتير
بتاعها ارتس مصور الحكايه دي ان العلاقه
بين الولايات المتحده ونتنياهو تحديدا هي
ان بنج فير ده كلب في ايد نتنياهو وماسك
الليش بتاعه الحبل دوت وبيسمع له ان هو
يقضي حاجته على بايض اه وياخد ياغض حاجته
وياخد راحته يعني اه يعني هو بيستخدم بن
غفير ل مضايقه او الضغط على
بيضته تحقي جزيل الشكر معالي الدكتور
ونلقاكم ان شاء الله على خير الاسبوع
المقبل ان شاء الله تحياتي لحضرتك
بالتوفيق الله يخليك شكرا جزيلا لحضراتكم
والى اللقاء